hallo mein name ist sich volker ja nicht
sagen worum es geht weil es im titel
eingeblendet see teil phone 7 mi das ei
phone 7 wurde ja vor einigen tagen
vorgestellt und ich habe danach nur doch
überall - darüber gesehen wie sich alle
wieder darüber lustig machen ich habe
selber schon über das neue iphone video
gemacht warum nicht hat nicht so gut
finde aber ich bin ja jetzt nicht so ein
krasser apple fanboy ich finds halt
immer witzig was kreative und witzige
köpfe sich im internet aus denken dann -
und alles über das neue iphone und
allgemeine paar neue sachen von apple
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht die suche
war elfte kraus und den fans übrigens
mal leichter wenn ihr wollt dass ich
öfter so sachen wie von mygate zeigt und
so einfach so - und alles mögliche keine
vorteile von sevenone ließ länger kennen
des teams über drei konzerten
das war quasi auslöser wie soll ich
jetzt dieses video auf nebenbei ich habe
dieses bild gesehen als ich einfach
iphone 7 googelt habe und da kann man
dieses bild ich habe gerade es gibt so
viele fakih miss ich zeige euch einfach
mal ein paar das nächste mihm ist dieses
hier und zwar bei saab von sixt alfons
apple comes out next day ist quasi genau
so wie ich gerade dabei die sorry hab
ich schon mal erzählt dass mehreren wie
mein handy geklaut wurde und nein das
hat überhaupt nichts mit feiern und
alkohol zu das finde ich auch cool und
zwar apple sagt sowie alfons hier und
dann kommen zu dieses typische patrick
mit drei dollar einer hand ist wenn mir
aber wirklich ähnlich überrascht uns
rauskommt denke ich mir nur so auch
eigentlich war hinter würden gerne nutzt
geld auszugeben und bild.de und dann
sind alle weil ich dann nicht alles
deutlich verstehe einfach nicht wie man
sich die plus version von dem iphone
holen kann also nichts gegen die leute
aber ich würde dich für mich ist es so
ein handy muss klein sein und handlich
um das plus kriege ich wahrscheinlich
nicht bei meiner hosentasche
da hab ich nämlich mit eine überspitzte
darstellung der größe von 7 + geworden
und zwar dass hier
ich will da nicht das hinführen soll
wenn sie plötzlich people bei android
based foul gibt es hat mehrere gründe
wie beispielsweise die eu-kassen weise
bilder die die value for money die
kostenlosen apps und die kostenlosen
private tabs und dann gibt es auch noch
warum leute ein einkauf und der haupt-
und dort ist die kapsel iphone
ich frage mich auch wie soll ich immer
wieder kaufe falls ihr euch übrigens das
iphone 7 nicht kaufen können weil es
ihnen wie gerade kein geld zur verfügung
habt oder bei denkt okay ihr wollt nicht
direkt wieder neues handy aber ihr wollt
irgendwie doch das ei phone 7 haben oder
das neueste einem habe ich auch ein tipp
vorbereitet hören von stacks intern
iphones bei pudding taylor aber die
herren von jack können wir später dann
so kriegt ihr jetzt sofort euer iphone 7
und jetzt kommen wir zu den minis auf
die alle gewartet haben es ist die
traurigste änderung die bei my phone 7
vorgestellt wurde
die scheiß kopfhörerbuchse
ich war okay apple liegt kostenlos einen
adapter damit dabei damit man ja noch
die alten kopfhörer benutzen kann und
typisch apple wäre eigentlich gewesen
deutlich ihr müsst euch ein adapter
kaufen
der kostet 400 dollar aber ich finde es
eigentlich ganz coole aktionen also ich
meine dadurch dass du dieses hat
formcheck jetzt weg gemacht haben ist es
jetzt möglich dass das ding
wahrscheinlich wasserresistent ist ich
glaube dass wir auch anders irgendwie
gegangen aber so erkläre ich mir das mal
aber es gibt auch sehr viele negative
gründe wie beispielsweise die kannst
dich sein iphone aufladen und musikhören
gleichzeitig vor allem wenn man irgendwo
hin will muss man immer diesen scheiß
adapter mitnehmen weil man das ding ja
irgendwie wenn man im auto sitzt mit
einem kumpel und der sagte hey hier hast
du aufs kabel will smoker machen muss
wohl gut weil adapter packt ihn immer
lieben und irgendwie fühle ich mich da
im jahr 2006 da gab es nämlich diese
sony walkman w700 handy mit auf so einem
scheiß adapter und jetzt gibt es halt
das iphone 716 sonnenscheins adapter
seitdem bescheuert wie ich gerade schon
gesagt hat man muss sich entscheiden
zwischen handy aufladen oder musik hören
und das ist ein voll bescheuert weil bei
mir isses daraus wenn ich fünf akku habe
aber gerade irgendwie in der bahn sitze
und nebenbei dann mein handy laden aber
noch musik hören will was habt ihr euch
dabei gedacht apple von sieben neuheit
von port 1 von 8 9 prozent die box geht
your money danke apple so wird
wahrscheinlich demnächst sein und hier
nochmal ein insider tipp an alle leute
die sich das iphone 7 holen aber nicht
auf den ihr von plattlings verzichten
können in that you sing hydro apples
neues produkt vor
really wanted von pol pot dieses tolle
apple-logo rahn das was ihr von dem
video meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen an last auf jeden fall leichter
wenn ich mehr von so was machen soll
es gibt noch so unzählig viele weitere
teams wie beispielsweise diese ganzen wo
diese neuen drahtlosen kopfhörer
vorgestellt wurden dann so vergleiche
mit einem fön und so das heißt ich
könnte dir über noch ein video machen
wir den bock habt dann schreibt dass man
den kommentaren wenn ihr noch kein
abonnent von einem kanal könnte jetzt
hier oben auf den smiley draufklicken
das ist nämlich so ein rad ab dingsbums
also vorne drauf klickt man könnte
meinen galan abonnieren und hier findet
ihr ein video über das iphone lieben
verlinkt wie soll ich sagen
durch das nicht so geil finde und was
ich daran asse informieren
ich wünsche einen schönen tag und
hoffenheim